die eltern von maddie waren an dem abend
tapas essen auf der anlage das ist der
ort den wir hier mit der nummer eins
gekennzeichnet hatten diese kleine
tapas-bar hier auf der ferienanlage ganz
im süden der algarve ganz im süden
portugals bis etwa 22 uhr da ist die
mama von medi einmal aufgestanden um zu
kontrollieren was ist mit den kindern
die man da alleine im zimmer in der
ferienanlage zurückgelassen hat nämlich
in diesem appartement und dazu ist die
mama erstmal aus der anlage rausgegangen
das war der normale weg zu dem
appartement erstmal über diese rezeption
das ist der punkt 2 hier raus kurz auf
die straße und dann zudem appartements
der mir kennen hier vorne was wir mit
punkt 3 gekennzeichnet haben also das
appartement zeigt zur straßenseite davor
eine mauer mann konnte von der tapas-bar
etwas die terrasse sehen aber mehr auch
nicht und der eingang befindet sich dann
hier direkt an der straße über die
terrasse zu ist auch die mama von medi
an diesem abend haben etwa 22 uhr dann
in dieses appartement reingekommen und
wir wollen noch ein detail zeigen dass
ganz ganz wichtig ist nämlich dieses
fenster hier auf der anderen seite des
appartements mit der vier gekennzeichnet
kann man noch einmal in groß zeigen dass
zeigt zur parkplatzseite das heißt hier
22 uhr es war mittlerweile dunkel im
sommer in portugal und dieses fenster
ist ganz schwer einzusehen von der
straße wie gesagt ein dunkler hof das
können wir uns nochmal und detail
angucken hier das appartement
appartement der familie
wir sehen hier wo mama von maddie 1
gekommen ist über die terrasse wie
gesagt vorher über die straße gelaufen
dann betritt sie hier das appartement
hier vorne ein wohnraum hier neben das
elternschlafzimmer und die kinder die
haben sich dann hier unten in diesem
kleinen zimmer aufgehalten haben die
zwillinge geschlafen in den beiden
betten und medi vermutlich hier vorne in
dem bett direkt am fenster und das stand
offen als die mama von maddie das
appartement betritt soll sie diesen wind
zug gespürt haben muss sich gewundert
haben offenbar steht ein fenster offen
tatsächlich stand eben dieses fenster
hier unten
zur straßenseite zur parkplatzseite
offen durch dieses fenster muss maddie
also offenbar entführt worden sein
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren